le premier témoignage sur la torture
pratiquée en algérie au moment des
émeutes d'il ya quinze jours c'est le
document de ce journal négociation en ce
moment même au ministère de la santé
aucun syndicat n'a fermière ne signerait
ce soir le protocole d'accord du minist
re présailles israélienne au sud liban
le djihad islamique menace de s'en
prendre aux otages américains
l'argent de la drogue ont cité en france
plusieurs banques travaillent pour le
compte du général noriega maître du
panama
ouverture aujourd'hui à paris de la
foire internationale d'art contemporain
d'aveux d'honneur de la sphère un pain
premier assure madame monsieur bonsoir
sakharov sakharov pendant des années ces
trois syllabes ont scandé le long combat
pour les droits de l'homme en union
soviétique
le sort du physicien prix nobel de la
paix la liberté de mouvement et
d'expression dont il jouit mesure à leur
manière l'évolution du régime soviétique
mikhaïl gorbatchev avait attendu près de
deux ans après son accession au pouvoir
suprême avant d'autoriser le savon à
revenir à moscou et bien trois semaines
après les important remaniement à la
tête du système soviétique
on apprend l'élection hier d'andré
sakharov au présidium de l'académie des
sciences du rss et voici que l'on
apprend aujourd'hui que pour la première
fois il va être autorisé à quitter
l'union soviétique pour se rendre le
mois prochain à washington
georges bortoli a réussi à le joindre au
téléphone
oui ça car un fait pratiquement sûr
d'aller aux états unis il vient de me le
confirmer et comme dans tabou dit
pendant six ans de 1981 1986
saint-carreuc exilé à gorki fut coupée
de tout lien avec le monde
seules les caméras du kgb le filmé
clandestinement quand il apparaissait à
sa fenêtre ou dans son jardin
et puis à la fin de l'année 86 sur
décision personnelle de mikhaïl
gorbatchev sakharov et sa femme sont
autorisés à regagner moscou sakharov
adopte alors à l'égard de monsieur
gorbatchev
attitude de soutien critique puis lui
vaudra d'être traité en personnage tout
à fait reconnu par le pouvoir et même de
donner les conférences de presse dans le
cadre tout à fait officiel du ministère
des affaires étrangères pour y répéter
oui à la veille stranka non aux
hésitations sur les droits de l'homme
elle était déjà à l'étranger lui jamais
les droits de l'homme les plus
élémentaires ont été bafoués en algérie
on devine est au delà de l'approximation
sur le nombre des victimes et des
arrestations que les émeutes d'octobre
avait été aussi la cause ou le prétexte
de toutes sortes de sévices
la rumeur courait à alger de torture
jacques merlino nous en avait parlé pour
la première fois ce soir antenne 2 est
en mesure de confirmer que des centaines
de personnes très souvent des enfants
arrêtés au moment de ces affrontements
sanglants ont été violemment maltraités
regardez le témoignage que nous ramène
d'alger bruno le dreff et jean cornu il
a 16 ans
les béquilles séquelles de tortures
subies pendant trois jours dans cette
pièce nous avons rencontré huit
personnes elles ont désiré témoigné
montrer leurs blessures ongles arrachés
au couteau pour brûler à l'électricité
coups de baïonnette dans les cuisses
marche à genoux sur du gravier du verre
filé cela s'est passé près d'alger du
vendredi 7 au dimanche 9 octobre nous
avons été acheminés vers des deux
polices de 007 qui ont aidé ici puis
livré la sécurité militaire qui nous
acheminer vers une cour militaire de
commandos parachutistes sidi ferruch
donc que s'est il passé dans ce camp là
les gens étaient dirigés vers des
endroits différents
la plupart des jeunes ont été jetés dans
une cave située à environ 600 le jeu
nous étions un groupe de cent personnes
environ
nous a placés dans des salles à partir
de 20h 20h30
les parachutistes monté par vagues passé
à tabac un certain nous faisait lever et
me passer à tabac repartez notre vague
venez vous faisait asseoir le passer à
tabac
et ainsi de suite jusqu'à environ 4h 5h
du matin là les opérations torture était
dirigée par des officiers de la sécurité
militaire et certains officiers de
rachitisme et une personnalité de la wii
derrière disons le préfet de cette
région qui a assisté au briefing avec
les officiers d'un cycle timide il ya eu
différentes formes de torture
les jeunes qui étaient dans la cave on
les faisait ramper sur les genoux ces
marchés sur les genoux le bastonner sur
le soir on le faisait sortir le faisait
ce courrier des mots d'ordre de vivre
mais je l'algérie vit fier de ce qu'ils
criaient près bien sûr été construits
quant à nous attend dans ce qu'on
appelait la villa susini
il y avait deux salles de torture une
salle d'interrogatoire de salles de
torture dans la salle d'interrogatoire
interrogé en bas se tourner les gens
mais bien évidemment il y avait une
salle où on pratiquait ce qu'on appelait
la baignoire les chiffons contraire tout
à l'heure comment opérer il y avait une
salle de sodomisation on faisait
pénétrer dans la liste des gens normaux
qui vient de me quitter grammont malades
cardiaques
d'ailleurs je préciserai que c'est que
cet ami était torturé en présence d'un
médecin militaire
les enfants aussi des tortures et
enfants de 13 qui étaient basses poney
et humaines j'en suis sûr des enfants
tir été violée les jeunes adolescents
qui était considéré qu'on est en grand
et ont-ils pris par des individus
parachutistes particulièrement un
adjudant odieux elles seraient ils ont
profité de la situation l'état de siège
d'ailleurs c'est ce que disaient les
officiers la sécurité militaire qui
profiteraient de l'état de siège c'est
pour ça d'ailleurs il s'agissait à
visage découvert ont vu les cicatrices
des gens qui pensaient que l'état de
siège allait durer longtemps et est même
question d'ailleurs de nous juger dans
le camp
pour ma part j'ai vécu une petite ironie
de l'histoire j'ai subi des violences
des parachutistes algérien une centaine
de mètres de l'endroit où mon père a été
torturé par des parachutistes français
les cicatrices de l'histoire est ouverte
et ce témoignage est terrible bruno le
dreff vous rentrez donc aujourd'hui
d'alger cet homme a accepté de témoigner
à visage découvert
vous serez nous serons tous évidemment
très attentifs ce qui pourrait lui
arriver à alger
en tout cas son témoignage illustre la
gravité des événements qui ont eu lieu
en algérie et aussi la protée on imagine
des luttes entre les factions au sein du
pouvoir
oui absolument christine une chose est
certaine et je crois que le reportage
que nous venons de regarder le prouve il
a eu torture et une répression terrible
sur quel ordre sous quelle autorité
vous l'avez entendu c'est l'armée qui
est fils est reste à savoir s'ils
opéraient en suivant des consignes
gouvernementales ou contraire si elle
voulait déstabiliser le pouvoir ou aux
contres ou enfin si elle croyait ainsi
le protéger hier lorsque j'ai interrogé
de hauts responsables algériens sur la
torture ils m'ont répondu qu'il
s'agissait selon eux de bavure c'est le
terme qui l'ont utilisé ils ont ajouté
que des enquêtes sont lancés que les
responsables seraient châtiés
depuis deux jours un collectif d'avocats
s'occupe d'ailleurs des victimes
ils peuvent travailler librement c'est
nouveau l'attitude des ailes des
autorités algériennes à l'égard du
témoin que nous avons entendu sera
d'ailleurs un test de sa volonté de
changement une volonté de changement qui
est espérée par tous les algériens que
j'ai pu rencontrer même s'il reste
encore très inquiets une volonté de
changement qui a cependant bien du mal à
s'affirmer
ainsi lorsque nous avons voulu vérifier
le nombre des victimes
il nous a été impossible de pénétrer
dans les hôpitaux dans les morgues ou
même dans les cimetières
on a enfin cité officiellement le
chiffre de 153 morts ce n'est en algérie
un secret pour personne que le nombre
des victimes est beaucoup plus élevé
la répression a bien été sanglante merci
bruno leur rédacteur en chef de la revue
de l'amicale des algériens en europe
l'émanation du parti unique algérien a
démissionné à paris la direction avait
refusé qu'il publie un article intitulé
plus jamais ça au terme d'une troisième
semaine de grève le conflit des
infirmières ne semble pas ce soir près
d'être réglé
la coordination nationale qui
s'apprêtent à manifester demain à paris
et en province aurait refusé les
contacts officieux que lui proposait le
gouvernement et ce soir les syndicats
sont en ce moment même dans le bureau du
ministre de la santé qui auraient
retouché certaine dose
proposition mais il semble que la
signature d'un protocole d'accord même
par deux syndicats n'est pas acquise eve
mettait tout n'est donc pas encore joué
au ministère de la santé les flics et
des relations syndicales font
actuellement à coude autour de la table
depuis plus d'une heure trente
la cgt a fait savoir dès le départ
qu'elle ne signerait pas l'accord
les autres fédérations soumettre leur
signature à de nouvelles conditions
et ce sont ces conditions vous [ __ ]
actuellement examinés le protocole
d'accord soumis aux syndicats cette fois
reprend les propositions que claude evin
avait fait le 13 octobre dernier une
nouvelle grille indiciaire qui
représente une hausse de salaire de 5
195 francs pour une infirmière débutante
764 concours une infirmière avec six ans
d'ancienneté et 1538 francs pour une
infirmière avec 15 ans d'ancienneté
les autres termes de l'accord concerne
la formation et le remplacement des
personnels en congés logiquement même si
le suspense continue
on peut penser que l'accord sera signé
ce soir font doute puisque deux
signatures suffisent pour qu'il soit
applicable
il faut rappeler que la coordination des
infirmières ce mouvement spontané il sut
de la base qui dès le départ a contesté
la représentativité des syndicats
organisent demain une manifestation une
sorte de baroud d'honneur et on devrait
donc en savoir plus plus tard dans la
soirée
claude evin avait rendu visite ce matin
aux infirmières en grève à saint nazaire
en province le mouvement le sait a donné
au fil des jours quelques signes
d'effritement ainsi à sablé dans la
sarthe
la grève avait été levée au début de la
semaine alors quel est l'état d'esprit
des infirmières qui ont repris le
travail
daniel duigou est aller le vérifier sur
place depuis lundi dernier les cinquante
cinq infirmières de l'hôpital de sable
et ont repris travail ainsi que les
aides soignantes et les aides
anesthésistes depuis le début du conflit
il ya tout juste trois semaines
les infirmières avaient décidé la grève
tenu des assemblées générales et
participé à des manifestations
régionales
mais depuis les propositions
gouvernementales de vendredi dernier
elle estime que poursuivre la grève
c'est faire plus de mal que de bien au
niveau de coordination sarthe nous avons
arrêté et décidé d'arrêter la grève
dans la mesure où les soins ne pouvait
étaient obligés de se faire pour le
bienfait du malade
donc on a tous décidé d'arrêter la grève
mais par contre nous allons faire une
information au niveau de la population
que ce soit au mans à sablé à mamers à
la ferté-bernard pour informer les gens
sur notre profession nous sommes quand
même à sable est une petite ville
consciente en tant qu'infirmière que les
patients que nous soignons sont des gens
vous croisant dans la rue tous les jours
et pour eux nous avons décidé de
reprendre le travail l'ambiance dans cet
hôpital de province qui a été construit
il ya à peine dix ans est sans doute
très différent de celle des grandes
structures parisiennes et des hôpitaux
des grandes villes en particulier la
proximité entre soignants et malades est
nettement plus grande
bon est ce qu'elles peuvent obtenir plus
maintenant je ne crois pas dans
l'immédiat il ya des problèmes qui sont
des problèmes qui ressorte du cadre de
la loi et il faut qu'à loi sur modifier
les infirmières ont cependant décidé de
rester en contact avec la coordination
nationale de participer demain samedi à
la manifestation à paris est informer
les malades sur les raisons du conflit
elles se tiennent prêtes à refaire grève
si nécessaire encore des arrêts de
travail aujourd'hui dans les ptt
notamment à rouen et surtout dans les
transports ainsi à nantes paralysie
complète pour la troisième journée
consécutive à paris à l'appel de la cgt
et du syndicat autonome traction
importantes perturbations ce soit encore
dans le métro et le rer perturbations
aussi à la sncf
à l'assemblée nationale les députés ont
poursuivi aujourd'hui l'examen des
recettes du projet de budget 89 pour
éviter l'opposition des centristes et
des communistes
le gouvernement a accepté d'amender
quelques dispositions clés notamment sur
la tva
pascal guimier claire chazal ans dont
amants dont il en restera toujours
quelque chose
litanie liturgie oui mais on a échappé
aujourd'hui à la léthargie rapprochement
entre gouvernement et centriste une
rencontre inopinée dit-on entre pierre
bérégovoy et raymond barre et le
gouvernement reprend à son compte des
amendements centristes le gouvernement
attentif à ce qui se dit sur les bancs
de l'assemblée envisage d'apporter des
correctifs au projet qu'elle a proposé
en clair baisse de la tva et de la taxe
professionnelle autant de gagné pour les
ménages comme pour les entreprises mais
surtout un gain politique de taille pour
michel rocard
les centristes seraient maintenant prêts
à s'abstenir sur le budget dans son
ensemble du donnant
des choses absolument indispensable
et tant mieux si la pression du
parlement et entre et la pression des
centristes poussent le gouvernement à
aller plus vite
reste évidemment le gros morceau du jour
et de la nuit à venir l'impôt sur la
fortune
là rien de neuf le gouvernement est
décidé à ne rien céder ni à droite ni à
gauche
une chose est sûre les communistes même
réticent voteront pour
récapitulons un budget contre lequel ne
voteront que le rpr et l'udf fasse un
impôt sur la fortune
approuvé à la fois par les socialistes
et par les communistes le gouvernement
ce soir peut respirer
michel rocard n'aura peut-être pas à
sortir de sa poche le fameux article 49
3 larmes suprême
le nec plus ultra de la dissuasion
parlementaire il est vrai que l'armée
plutôt encombrant en ces temps de
conflits sociaux plutôt encombrant aussi
quand on se dit quand on se veut le
champion de l'ouverture politique
comment gagner 50 kg de viande par tête
de boeuf une société de distribution de
produits alimentaires pour bétail avait
trouvé le filon limited de bétail dans
plusieurs élevages du nord de la france
ont été dopés et nouri al- anabolisants
comme ben johnson le trafic a été
démantelé et son maître d'oeuvre est
écroué à béthune maryse mano belle prise
pour la gendarmerie de ville ces
échantillons de composer vitamines et
contiennent le fameux clembutérol witten
de cet aliment du bétail ont été saisis
de quoi engraisser des milliers de bêtes
quand on sait que 20 grammes de produit
pur engendre 30 tonnes de viande
l'importateur habitait à lens à la fois
marchands de journaux et distributeur
d'aliments
il a été inculpé et écroué à la grande
surprise du voisinage
moi j'ai jamais rien vu d'anormal s'il
dit jamais perry s'est procuré de la
marchandise et qui ensuite la a effectué
une première préparation qu'il a remises
à des fabricants d'aliments pour bétail
mais sans leur dire ce qu'il y avait
dans le produit de base
bizarre car les éleveurs acheter
l'aliment au prix de la viande 25 francs
le kilo au lieu de 10 francs cours
normal en fait des services de
gendarmerie mots confiés une liste
de gros consommateurs en quelque sorte
ça va de 400 kg à quelques tonnes du
complexe minéral vitaminé pada
substances à l'état pur
ce qui nous permet est ce qui nous a
permis déjà dès ce matin avec avec les
services de gendarmerie d'intervenir
dans un certain nombre d'élevages pour
les mettre sous surveillance
il semble que le trafic de produits
prohibés augmente depuis que la
communauté européenne a interdit tous
les anabolisants
c'est le principe de la prohibition dès
qu'un produit est interdit il fait
l'objet d'un marché noir
éleveurs et trafiquants font le pari qui
ne se font pas prendre
seulement voilà cette fois ils ont été
pris et ils risquent gros en tout cas
grâce aux contrôles vétérinaires les
bêtes ne pourront pas être conduite à
l'abattoir et de toute façon le danger
du produit en cas de consommation n'est
pas prouvée pour l'ogs le suspense
continue pour les français les allemands
et les japonais qui se disputent le
marché du tgv espagnol à madrid le
conseil des ministres de ce matin a
reporté sa décision et demandé aux
chemins de fer ibérique un rapport
complémentaire sans calendrier précis
l'amérique criminelle doit savoir
qu'elle n'échappera pas au châtiment
notamment ce qui concerne les otages que
nous détenons c'est en ces termes que de
beyrouth
le djihad islamique menace de se venger
sur deux auteurs américains après les
représailles menées ce matin par
l'aviation israélienne au sud liban
israël a ainsi riposter à l'attentât à
la voiture piégée contre un convoi de
son armée mercredi dernier bilan du raid
aérien au moins neuf morts martine
laroche-joubert une riposte est clair
l'aviation israélienne d'école ce matin
direction le sud liban premier raid sur
les positions palestinienne à l'est de
saïda un dépôt de munitions explosent
après un tir de missile 3 meur deuxième
attaque sur malgara l'un des fiefs du
hezbollah
son quartier général est détruit une
cynique aussi six personnes il trouve la
mort dont deux infirmières et un enfant
bilan de cette journée au moins neuf
morts et 25 blessés
des chiffres qui ajoutait aux sept
soldats israéliens tués ya 48 heures
provoque une escalade du désir de
vengeance de part et d'autre les
israéliens n'ont rien à faire au libre
déclare ce palestinien jérusalem
ils ne sont pas supposés y aller
d'accord riposte d'un israélien il doit
savoir que s'ils font quelque chose
nos régions une tension qui approche des
élections israéliennes provoque un
renforcement du dispositif de sécurité
par la zone tampon entre le liban et
israël
selon l'ol paie israël se préparait à
une autre opération terrestre cette fois
au liban sud
le roi hussein de jordanie lance un pavé
dans la campagne électorale israélienne
si l'attentât au sud-liban joue plutôt
en faveur des durs du likoud de l'actuel
premier ministre shamir hussein lui
soutient ouvertement le travailliste
shimon peres une victoire de chamiers
revient-il de dire serait un désastre
pour le processus de paix au
moyen-orient s'il a dit à une chaîne
américaine nbc en revanche les
propositions de shimon peres représente
un pas en avant a dit le roi hussein
comment l'argent de la drogue par
millions de dollars et il blanchit vous
vous souvenez de l'incroyable
feuilletons que nous vous racontions la
semaine dernière de la chute de cette
banque à luxembourg qui s'était
spécialisé dans le recyclage financier
de ces énormes sommes au cours de l'
enquête menée conjointement par les
etats-unis la grande-bretagne et la
france
la justice américaine avait arrêté une
dizaine de trafiquants tous proches de
l'homme fort du panama
le général noriega michel mompontet est
maintenant en mesure de nous expliquer
les penchants très français du général
pour la première fois les images d'une
commission secrète
nous sommes au département de justice
américain section trafic international
de stupéfiants
mais un homme vient à la barre il se
fait appeler florine kardon cassé d'un
faune euros la tête est mise à prix par
les trafiquants latino-américain 30
millions de dollars
il les a trahis il a parlé avec ce
témoignage la plus fantastique enquête
sur le recyclage de l'argent de la
drogue
vite un moment décisif quelle était
votre rôle lui demande
dons collectés la cocaïne depuis la
colombie aux états unis et rapporter
l'argent au panama là je leur mettait au
général noriega se faisait environ 36
milliards de francs par an un nom
revient sans cesse dans ses accusations
manuel noriega le général l'homme fort
de panama
c'est lui le véritable noyau de
l'organisation officiellement sa solde
de militaire n'est que de 7600 francs
par mois
en fait nous apprend le carlton ses
activités illégales lui ont procuré une
fortune évaluée aujourd'hui à plus de 60
milliards de francs écouler cette somme
colossale voilà l'unique problème de
noriega première étape alors des
centaines de valises comme celle ci
bourré de dollars que l'on dépose tout
simplement au guichet des banques
étrangères a fixé au panama dans ces
banques aucune question sur la
provenance de ces fonds
elles ont toutes un point commun des
filiales dans le monde entier
deuxième étape faire sortir cet argent
du panama pour en effacer les origines
on est en moule blanchir et c'est là
qu'entre en scène notre personnage
capitale josé blanc dont le consul de
panama à new york
en fait conseiller très spécial de
noriega quelle était votre fonction lui
demande-t-on blanchir l'argent pour
noriega 60 millions de francs par
semaine
ma technique est sain attendre les
banques vionnet elle-même nous proposer
leurs services
mes partenaires étaient la citibank la
chase manhattan la banque de boston la
bcc en fait la liste est interminable
quelle était votre préféré la bn à paris
noriega l'estimé beaucoup c'est lui qui
me le répéter pas une semaine sans faire
passer par un jeu d'écritures de
l'argent via paris veut l'argent qu'ils
repartent et mes propres vers le panama
rue lulli à paris une des filiales de la
bn on nie tout ces accusations sont
ridicules techniquement inimaginable
on reconnaît bien l'existence d'une
filiale de la bm à panama mais on
affirme ignorer tout de ses activités
locales plusieurs témoins panaméen ont
pourtant confirmé devant cette
commission du sénat les accusations de
blanc donne la france aurait donc été
elle aussi séduite par l'argent de
noriega la récente arrestation dans la
sphère de la banque bci semble le
prouver
inimaginable il suffit pourtant d'ouvrir
n'importe quel journal international
pour trouver ce genre de texte service
totalement confidentielles
disponibilités financières immédiates
relais dans le monde entier
en réalité derrière ces petites annonces
se cacher les millions de dollars du
blanchiment de l'argent de la drogue
plus démodé mais le trafic continue 36
tonnes de cigarettes blondes ont été
saisis a marseille une vingtaine de
contrebandiers ont été interpellés c'est
demain que la cour d'assises spéciale de
bordeaux doit rendre son verdict dans le
procès de charles pieri et félix tommasi
les deux chefs présumés de l'ex effet
l'insee accusé d'assassinât l'avocat
général a prononcé aujourd'hui au
réquisitoire plutôt modéré que les
nationalistes corses considère déjà
comme une provocation
emmanuel vanier
dix ans de réclusion c'est la peine
requise par l'avocat général de bordeaux
contre les deux militants de l'ex
valencic accusé d'avoir assassiné un
légionnaire en février 82 l'avocat
général n'a évoqué que la complicité
d'assassinât aucune preuve at il dit
n'ayant été rapporté de leur
participation directe
ces réquisitions ont cependant été
qualifiée de véritable provocation par
les nationalistes corses pour compenser
une éventuelle sévérité du verdict
attendu demain
le ministère de la justice vient
d'ordonner le regroupement des détenus
de l'ex flnc dans deux prisons
ce regroupement était l'une des
principales revendications des
nationalistes corses
détournement de fonds et complicité de
détournement ferdinand marcos et sa
femme viennent d'être inculpés par un
procureur new yorkais qui enquête depuis
plus de deux ans sur les activités de
l'ex dictateur philippin ferdinand
marcos réfugiés aux îles hawaii aurait
détourné 620 millions de francs pour
acheter quatre immeubles à new york
les oeuvres d'art et des objets précieux
il pourrait être également inculpés de
raquette association de malfaiteurs et
escroquerie
le milliardaire saoudien adnan khashoggi
et lui inculpé de complicité pour lui
avoir servi de prête-nom mer rouge en
rade de brest collision entre un navire
militaire la jeanne d'arc et ce cargo
chargé de milton de vins italiens
plusieurs que faisait rentrer dans le
pinard dié avarie légère pour la jeanne
qui pourra partir normalement fin
novembre pour sa croisière annuel l'
affaire papon rebondi après la
confirmation ici même hier soir par
l'ancien ministre de sa nouvelle
inculpation pour crime contre l'humanité
et aussi ses violentes dénégations vous
l'avez vu face aux nouveaux témoignages
que nous avions produit maurice mathis
on a décidé à son tour de saisir la
justice
il est déjà l'une des parties civiles
depuis le début de la faire par ailleurs
maurice sabatier
l'ancien préfet de gironde pendant la
guerre qui était le supérieur
hiérarchique de maurice papon a été
inculpé à son tour de crimes contre
l'humanité feu vert pour tdf 1 le
gouvernement a confirmé aujourd'hui que
le lancement du satellite de diffusion
français aura bien lieu à kourou le 27
octobre prochain
après de sérieuses remises en cause sur
son utilité il aurait donc trouver des
clients
mais c'est une autre affaire qui remuent
ce soir le paysage audiovisuel français
donnant partiellement raison à tefel
conseil d'état en effet annulé la
plupart des décisions de la cncl qui
avait attribué à la 5 et à m6 des
nouveaux émetteurs olivet lerner et
véronique saint-élie la cinq et m6 au
piquet victimes des plaintes à
répétition déposé devant le conseil
d'état par tf1 les deux plus petites des
chaînes privées qui couvrait depuis
quelques mois 70 % du territoire sont
menacés d'être privé de plusieurs
millions de téléspectateurs
autorisation d'émettre pourtant accordé
par la cncl annulé pour m6 au mans et
dans la région rhône-alpes annulé pour
l'a5 en partie en seine-et-marne et dans
l'allier audimat oblige la 5 est
désormais s'ouvrir à une à une attitude
dominatrice et agressive
il ya quelques temps là une attente est
devant les tribunaux n'empêchait l'a5
d'avoir des images des jeux olympiques
je remercie d'ailleurs antenne 2 de nous
avoir soutenus à cette occasion y est
la une a tenté d'empêcher la 5 de faire
des passes et des faits des films
érotiques
aujourd'hui elle tente d'empêcher nos
émetteurs de massa sera autre chose il
faudrait que tf1 choisir une fois pour
toutes
entre le béton et la communication il ne
s'agit en fait que d'une simple
maladresse administrative
la cncl promet de reprendre la procédure
d'attribution
mais entre eux privés la hache de guerre
n'est pas pour autant enterrée en
exclusivité sur un thème de fr3 le
tennis à partir de lundi prochain avec
le tournoi de bercy
le tirage au sort des rencontres a eu
lieu ce soir tous les grands joueurs
seront larges en amer mats wilander le
numéro un mondial en tête les grands
noms du tennis sont au rendez vous de ce
3ème open de bercy il y aura également
miroslav mecir le champion olympique en
titre de séoul avec ses deux dauphins
mayotte et gilbert il y aura john
mcenroe et le français henri leconte en
compagnie de trois autres français
forget tulasne et est champion un tirage
au sort d'ailleurs qui n'a pas été très
heureux pour les français puisque nous
aurons au premier tour en explosifs le
comte mcenroe ensuite forgé rencontrera
un qualifié
malheureusement tulasne rencontrera le
suisse jakob hlasek enfin thierry
champion sera opposé à tim mayotte
le vainqueur de l'an dernier facile
premier tour je dirais pour messire et
mayotte
vous aurez bien sûr le compte rendu de
toutes ces péripéties du tout ces
rencontres tout au long de la semaine
sur antenne 2 premier rendez vous lundi
soir à 22h45 et ce soir inauguration au
grand palais à paris de la fiat la foire
internationale d'art contemporain qui
pour la quinzième année consécutive
réunis à paris les galeries et les
peintres qui expriment les courants du
temps cette fois ci l'espagne est à
l'honneur une douzaine de galeries
espagnole exposera la fiac et prouve
l'extraordinaire vitalité de la peinture
contemporaine dans ce pays qui explose
dans ce domaine là comme dans d'autres
voilà pourquoi c'est un peintre qui
figure ce soir à notre tableau d'honneur
de la semaine
il est espagnol eduardo à rouhia bonsoir
cet hommage à la peinture espagnole
selon vous c'est aussi un
maj à la movida à cette extraordinaire
développement d'espagne depuis le
rétablissement de la démocratie
oui l'espagne est à l'honneur
effectivement c'est à dire que la fiac a
décidé d'inviter un pays qui devient
comme les autres avec ses peintres ce
musée sa passion sa vitalité pour l'art
contemporain ce taux que que c'est une
source est un fait et la fiac l'a fait
alors vous avez vécu très longtemps en
exil à paris maintenant est-ce que vous
retournez en espagne vous y vivez à
nouveau j'ai pas prévient saisit et vous
avez longtemps vécu à paris en exil
maintenant vous travaillez à nouveau en
espagne où vous restez là non c'est à
dire que je voulais je vais partager un
peu mais j'ai mes ateliers à paris et à
madrid et j'ai peint d'enlever endroit
alors si vous nous entendez mal c'est
parce que et on l'entend là il ya le
brouhaha de l'inauguration qui a lieu en
ce moment derrière vous ce génie créatif
espagnol au fil des siècles et
singulièrement en ce moment et ce qu'il
prouve aussi que l'environnement
politique et économique peut compter
dans la peinture
ben c'est beaucoup de mal à saisir
est ce que les conditions actuelles en
espagne from je crie plus fort est ce
que les conditions actuelles en espagne
favori selon vous cet élan de l'art
espagnol oui certainement je pense que
l'espagne est un pays maintenant aller
beaucoup de curiosité beaucoup
d'hésitations complément reebok m'en
passer passé est finie c'est à dire qu'
il est plus récent chez derrière les
pyrénées et je crois que à la fiac
évidemment on peut voir le résultat des
sept g7 fait incontestable c'est certain
alors un ses résultats c'est évidemment
vos propres oeuvres on voit un tableau
derrière vous mais vous êtes aussi
sculpteur alors quel est le prix de ce
que l'on voit là
je l'attends très mal quel est le prix
du tableau que l'on que l'on aperçoit
derrière vous et eduardo arroyo
mais moi je crois que vous allez on
parle beaucoup d'argent c'est normal
c'est un marché c'était et c'est un
marché incontestable c'est une il faut
parler d'argent mais moi je pense que ce
qui est intéressant de voir c'est la
passion énorme que de plus en plus dans
7 pays suscite la comté pour un et je
dois dire que un pays comme la france
jugé après très littéraire je pense que
devient de plus en plus plus picturales
eduardo arroyo merci et donc si vous
voulez savoir les prix et bien
précipitez-vous au grand palais donc à
la fiac alors très rapidement encore les
pronostics de pierrette brès pour le
tiercé de demain à auteuil le 4 le 8 le
6 le 1 le 3 le 11 le 16 et le 5 à 22h50
henri sannier vous présentera notre
dernier journal demain pour
l'information sur antenne 2 vous avez
rendez vous avec daniel bilalian et
bernard rapp pour l'assiette anglaise
merci d'avoir suivi ce journal très bon
week end et à lundi